MATT GAETZ, I WOULD KEEP YOU
BOTH LONGER, BUT SOMEBODY ELSE
THINKS YOU.
THEY ARE UP NEXT.
JOINING US RIGHT NOW, LIVE ON
THE PHONE, EXCLUSIVE INTERVIEW
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE TONIGHT,
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP.
MR. PRESIDENT, THANK YOU FOR
BEING WITH US.
>> President Trump: WELL,
THANK YOU.
THEY DID A VERY GOOD JOB, I WILL
SAY.
>> Sean: OKAY.
[LAUGHS]
ME GO TO THE WOODWARD BOOK.
I WAS SURPRISED YOU SPOKE TO
HIM.
I DON’T THINK A LOT OF GOOD
COMES FROM TALKING TO BOB
WOODWARD, MY OWN PERSONAL
OPINION.
LET’S GO TO THE THINGS KARL ROVE
WAS POINTING OUT, THAT BIDEN
SAID TODAY, TEN DAYS AFTER THE
FIRST IDENTIFIED CASE, TEN DAYS,
YOU PUT THE TRAVEL BAN IN
EFFECT, AND IT WAS A SUBSEQUENT
BAND, FIRST QUARANTINED IN OVER
50 YEARS, HE SAID IT WAS
HYSTERICAL, XENOPHOBIA, AND
FEARMONGERING ON YOUR PART.
TWO AND A HALF MONTHS LATER, HE
REVERSED HIMSELF, AT LEAST
ACCORDING TO A CAMPAIGN AD.
WHAT DO YOU BELIEVE THAT ONE
DECISION -- TEN DAYS AFTER THE
FIRST CASE IN AMERICA, WHAT
IMPACT DID THAT HAVE COME AND
WHAT WERE YOU SAYING TO BOB
WOODWARD?
>> President Trump: FIRST OF
ALL, ON THE WOODWARD BOOK, ON
THE BOOK ITSELF, I DIDN’T
PARTICIPATE IN HIS LAST ONE, AND
HE DOES HIT JOBS WITH EVERYBODY.
HE EVEN DID IT ON OBAMA,
CONSTANT HIT JOBS COME ON BUSH,
I GUESS THEY DID THREE BOOKS,
THEY WERE ALL TERRIBLE, SO I
FIGURED, LET’S GIVE IT A LITTLE
SHOT, IT WASN’T A BIG DEAL, I
SPEAK TO HIM, I DON’T KNOW IF
THE BOOK IS GOOD OR BAD, I HAVE
NO IDEA, PROBABLY, ALMOST
DEFINITELY I WON’T READ IT
BECAUSE I DON’T HAVE TIME TO
READ IT, BUT I GAVE IT A LITTLE
BIT OF A SHOT.
SOUNDS LIKE IT’S NOT GOING TO BE
GOOD, BUT IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT I
SAID TODAY, I SAID DON’T PANIC,
WE DON’T WANT TO BE JUMPING UP
AND DOWN AND GOING WILD, DON’T
PANIC.
I’M A CHEERLEADER FOR THIS
COUNTRY, AND I DON’T WANT TO SEE
PANIC, AND I DID WHAT MATT SAID
WAS FANTASTIC, BECAUSE WE
WOULD HAVE LOST 2 MILLION,
2.5 MILLION LIVES INSTEAD OF
NUMBER WE ARE TALKING ABOUT,
ANYTHING ABOVE 1 IS NO GOOD, IT’
NO GOOD, WE CAN’T HAVE IT, IT
WAS CHINA’S FAULT, THEY
SENT IT TO US, IT WAS NO GOOD,
BUT I THOUGHT I WOULD GIVE THE
BOB WOODWARD SOME TIME, I GAVE
HIM SOME TIME, BUT AS USUAL,
WITH THE BOOKS HE WRITES, THAT
DIDN’T WORK OUT.
PERHAPS, I DON’T KNOW, MAYBE
IT’S GOOD, WHO KNOWS?
BUT AS FAR AS THE TIMING IS
CONCERNED, I DID SOMETHING VERY
IMPORTANT, AS YOU KNOW, AT THE
END OF JANUARY, I BANNED -- I
BANNED CHINA, BECAUSE THE PEOPLE
FROM CHINA, THEY WERE HEAVILY
INFECTED, AND I HAD A LOT OF
PEOPLE, INCLUDING DR. FAUCI --
AND I DON’T SAY THAT WITH
DISRESPECT, THAT’S REALLY WHAT
HE BELIEVED, BUT A LOT OF PEOPLE
BELIEVE THAT, THAT WE SHOULDN’T
BAN THEM, THAT IT WAS NO REASON
TO BAN THEM, AND BIDEN WAS GOING
AROUND FOR MANY WEEKS AFTER THAT
SAYING IS NOT EVEN GOING TO BE A
PROBLEM.
YOU COVERED IT INCREDIBLY.
ACTUALLY, KARL ROVE COVERED THAT
INCREDIBLY TONIGHT, AND JUST
INCREDIBLY, ACTUALLY.
THEY WERE ALL GOING AROUND, NO
PROBLEM, NO PROBLEM --
EVERYBODY.
PRACTICALLY EVERYBODY.
NOBODY HAD ANY IDEA IT WOULD BE
AS VIOLENT AS IT TURNED OUT TO
BE, AND WE STUDIED IT, WE
UNDERSTAND IT, NOW WE ARE
OPENING UP, BUT WE COULD’VE LOST
2 MILLION, 2.5 MILLION, MAYBE
EVEN MORE THAN THAT IF WE DID IT
A DIFFERENT WAY, AND WE’VE DONE
A REALLY GOOD JOB, BUT IF YOU
LOOK AT OUR NUMBERS, OUR
FATALITY NUMBERS COMPARED TO
OTHER COUNTRIES, WE ARE IN
REALLY -- I MEAN, IT’S AMAZING,
WHAT WE’VE DONE.
WE’VE BEEN ABLE TO DO SOMETHING
THAT A COUNTRY, ESPECIALLY WITH
THE KIND OF SIZE WE ARE DEALING
WITH, WE’VE DONE AN INCREDIBLE
JOB.
>> Sean: I WATCHED YOUR PRESS
CONFERENCE TODAY, AND THE
GENERAL TONE OF THE QUESTIONING
WAS THAT YOU MISLED THE COUNTRY
BECAUSE YOU TOLD BOB WOODWARD ON
FEBRUARY 7TH, THIS LOOKS LIKE
IT’S GOING TO BE FIVE TIMES AS
BAD AS A NORMAL FLU VIRUS.
I THINK MOST AMERICANS MAY NOT
EVEN KNOW THAT THERE ARE YEARS,
WITH THE INFLUENZA VIRUS, THAT
WE LIVE IS TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
AMERICANS, NOT UNCOMMON.
BUT YOUR ACTIONS TEN DAYS
EARLIER TO PUT A TRAVEL BAN IN
EFFECT, A QUARANTINE IN EFFECT,
AGAIN, HASN’T BEEN DONE IN 50
YEARS, SO ACTION MEANS SOMETHING
SERIOUS IT WAS VERY CLEAR THEN,
AND YOU SAY I DON’T WANT PEOPLE
TO PANIC, WELL, THEY SAY YOU
MUST HAVE BEEN DOWNPLAYING IT,
WHAT IN YOUR ACTOR ACTIONS
CONTRADICT THAT NARRATIVE?
>> President Trump:
ABSOLUTELY.
IF YOU LOOK, WE HAVE HAD FLU
YEARS WHERE WE LOST 70, 80,
90,000 PEOPLE.
PEOPLE DON’T REALIZE THAT.
YOU LOOK AT THAT AND MULTIPLY
THAT TIMES FIVE, IT’S ACTUALLY
MORE.
THEN WE LOST.
WE COULD’VE LOST 2 MILLION,
2.5 MILLION, AS MATT SAID, IF WE
DID IT A DIFFERENT WAY, BUT WHAT
I WANT TO SHOW AS I WANT TO SHOW
A CALMNESS.
I’M THE LEADER OF THE COUNTRY, I
CAN’T BE JUMPING UP AND DOWN AND
SCARING PEOPLE.
I DON’T WANT TO SCARE PEOPLE.
I WANT PEOPLE NOT TO PANIC, AND
THAT’S EXACTLY WHAT I DID.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE
REPRESENTATIVES OF JOE BIDEN,
YOU SEE WHAT THEY WERE SAYING.
THEY WERE SAYING NO PROBLEM,
THIS WON’T BE A PROBLEM, HE
DIDN’T THINK IT WAS HIM TO BE A
PROBLEM UNTIL MONTHS LATER.
HE WAS WAY LATE.
PELOSI WAS WAY, WAY LATE, AND I
WAS AT THE END OF JANUARY, FAR
AHEAD OF EVERYBODY BECAUSE I DID
SOMETHING NOBODY WANTED ME TO
DO.
NOBODY WANTED ME TO DO THE BAN
ON CHINA, AND AS YOU KNOW,
SHORTLY THEREAFTER, I DID A BAN
ON EUROPE, AND I WAS EVEN MORE
CONTROVERSIAL, AND I WAS GOOD,
BECAUSE I SAW WHAT WAS GOING ON
IN ITALY AND IN SPAIN AND IN
FRANCE, AND WE DID A BAND THERE,
AND IF WE DIDN’T DO THOSE BANDS,
WE WOULD HAVE A NUMBERS THAT
WERE MUCH, MUCH MORE, AND IF WE
DIDN’T DO THE SHUTDOWN AND NOW
THE REOPENING, AND THEY SHOULD
DO THE OPENING FASTER, IF YOU
LOOK AT SOME OF THE STATES LIKE
NORTH CAROLINA, PENNSYLVANIA,
YOU LOOK AT WHAT THEY ARE DOING,
THEY ARE TAKING -- THEY ARE SHUT
DOWN, THEY ARE STILL SHUT DOWN.
MICHIGAN IS TERRIBLE.
IT IS STILL SHUTDOWN.
AND THAT’S A SHAME.
IT’S A SHAME.
THEY DON’T KNOW WHAT THEY’RE
DOING, FRANKLY, BUT THEY SHOULD
ALL BE OPENED, AND OUR COUNTRY
IS DOING VERY WELL, WE HAVE
RECORD NUMBERS OF JOBS.
USE ALL THE NUMBERS, JUST CAME
OUT, FOR THE FOUR MONTHS,
LARGEST NUMBER EVER, BY FAR, NOT
EVEN CLOSE, AND RETAIL SALES,
THE SAME THINGS, ITS RECORD
NUMBERS, SO WE ARE OPENING UP
WITH A STRONG V, NOT JUST, A
STRONG V.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A
TREMENDOUS YEAR NEXT YEAR, A
VERY GOOD QUARTER, AND THAT IS
GOING TO BE ANNOUNCED BEFORE THE
ELECTION.
>> Sean: THERE IS VOTING GOING
ON NOW.
YOU SEE JOE BIDEN, HE MAKES VERY
FEW APPEARANCES, THE MEDIA SEEMS
TO BE -- I DON’T
THINK HE HAS ANSWERED 100
QUESTION SINCE MARCH.
YOU KNOW, YOU’VE ANSWERED A
COUPLE THOUSAND PLUS QUESTIONS
IN THAT PERIOD OF TIME.
DO YOU THINK THE MEDIA IS GIVING
HIM A PASS?
DO YOU SEE -- LOOK, EVERYBODY
THAT I MEET, THAT I RUN INTO,
EVERYWHERE, AND EVEN PEOPLE IN
THE MEDIA, INTERESTINGLY,
QUIETLY, IN DEMOCRATS, I KNOW,
QUIETLY, ARE SAYING JOEL LOOKS
LIKE HE IS WEAK AND HE IS FRAIL.
HOW DO YOU INTERPRET JOE BIDEN,
THE BASEMENT BUNKER STRATEGY
COME HIS UNWILLINGNESS TO TAKE
QUESTIONS?
>> President Trump: WELL, THE
MEDIA IN TERMS OF WHAT THEY ARE
DOING IS WORSE THAN WHAT YOU ARE
SAYING, BECAUSE IT LOOKS TO
ME LIKE WHAT THEY ARE DOING
IS ASKING A QUESTION AND HE IS
READING AN ANSWER AT THE
TELEPROMPTER.
THAT WOULD MEAN, LIKE YOUR
FRIEND OVER THERE, DONNA BRAZILE
DONNA BRAZILE, WHO FOX
BRILLIANTLY HIRED --
>> Sean: SOUNDS LIKE YOUR
FAVORITE HOST.
>> DONNA BRAZILE IS ANOTHER REAL
GREAT ONE.
IT WOULD LOOK LIKE ME HE HAS
BEEN GIVEN THE QUESTIONS, AND HE
IS READING THE ANSWERS, BUT THAT
WOULD MEAN THE MEDIA IS GIVING
HIM THE QUESTIONS -- THEY NEVER
GAVE ME THE QUESTIONS, I CAN
TELL YOU THAT.
IT’S LIKE, WE HAVE SOME PRETTY
WILD TIMES, BUT THEY HIT ME WITH
THE WORST POSSIBLE QUESTIONS
POSSIBLE, AND YOU HAVE TO LEARN
TO DO IT, AND YOU HAVE TO BE
ABLE TO DO IT, AND IF YOU CAN’T
DO IT, YOU CAN’T BE A
POLITICIAN.
YOU CERTAINLY CAN’T REPRESENT
OUR COUNTRY, BECAUSE WHEN YOU
DEAL WITH PRESIDENT XI AND PUTIN
AND KIM JONG UN AND ALL OF THE
PEOPLE YOU HAVE TO DEAL WITH,
AND ALL THE RESPECT TO THE
MEDIA, THEY ARE MUCH TOUGHER,
THEY ARE MUCH SMARTER THAN THE
PEOPLE I HAVE TO DEAL WITH IN
THE VARIOUS ROOMS AND OUTSIDE BY
THE HELICOPTERS AND ALL THE
PLACES I AM WILLING ALWAYS TO
TAKE QUESTIONS, BUT I DON’T GET
ANY HELP IN TERMS OF, HERE IS
THE QUESTION, AND YOU CAN READ
AN ANSWER TO IT.
I NEVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE IT,
AND FRANKLY, I THINK THE MEDIA
IS DISGRACING THEMSELVES, BUT
IT’S OBVIOUS THAT JOE IS READING
THE ANSWERS OFF A TELEPROMPTER
COME IN MANY CASES.
THAT HAPPENED YESTERDAY WHEN HE
SAID "MOVE IT CLOSER."